[Musique]
lux art de vivre paillettes et services
palace pour star et grandes fortunes
décryptage aux quatre coins de la
planète
côté face des univers de rêve et de luxe
pour célébrités et riches clients côté
pile les coulisses d'un business avec
ses codes ses secrets et ses exigences
de stars perdu au coeur du désert en
plein milieu du maroc et même pas au
bord de la mer une ville devenue
mondialement célèbre marrakech le soleil
à 2h30 de paris des palais beau à couper
le souffle et des fêtes où l'on se
croirait à ibiza et où les stars et
leurs amis s'amusent mais toujours en
sécurité
très agréable d'anciens dhr de gardes du
corps
c'est palace qui rivalisent de luxe et
d'originalité pour attirer les riches et
célèbres choyé par tous et à qui on ne
peut rien refuser le matin quand on se
réveille coupe c'est une petite piscine
piscine d'amour aux ailes à combien elle
est à 29
quelles sont les prestations de ses
hôtels pour star quelles sont les plus
grandes folies
si je vous dis que leonardo dicaprio il
a il ne m'en voudra pas lui en général
et choisit plutôt une villa où il y a
deux appartements de deux chambres
parce que il a peut-être une vie privée
très très intenses avec des demoiselles
qui changent souvent qui se ressemblent
d'ailleurs souvent avant eux d'autres
stars ont fait la fortune de la ville en
star à sion les riads c'est pas les
typiques du centre ville qui aujourd'hui
font rêver et se vendent des fortunes
cet emplacement qui est un des meilleurs
de la médina c'est un bien qui serait
estimée autour d'un million d'euros
voilà pour la face connus mais nous
irons aussi dans les coulisses de ce
nouvel eldorado du luxe où les villas
somptueusement décoré cache un secret
connu des seuls initiés
bienvenue au royaume de la copie des
commerçants du souk aux plus grands
décorateurs
c'est une pièce sur mesure comme sa
saison je pense qu'on sera dans les 25e
dollars et si c'est une chose qu'on
arrive à sortir à 7000 $ alors comment
marrakech la cités impériales du maroc
est elle devenue le nouveau saint tropez
divers
plongez dans l'univers des célébrités
des milliardaires mais aussi de ceux qui
sont à leur service
un monde hors norme où tous les rêves
sont permis à condition d'être une star
[Musique]
une calèche attelée à une paire de
chevaux une allée pavée et illuminé qui
conduit à un palais des mille et une
nuits de 10 mille mètres carrés voici la
dernière folie de marrakech un palace
cinq étoiles qui tentent de mélanger le
traditionnel marocain au bollywood
indien
dans la calèche carole et olaf de
montjalin fortune de la bourse de new
york qui gère un fonds d'investissement
américain s'est pas n'y fit ce couple de
français richissime ne fréquente que la
jet set internationale
[Musique]
regard ça
c'est incroyable mais ce soir ils font
partie d'une centaine de clientes est
chargé de donner leur avis sur ce nouvel
hôtel aux allures de palais de
maharadjahs qu'ils soient français
américains russes ou même indien ils ont
plein les yeux et pourtant ils en ont vu
d'autres
cet hôtel est très comparable au palais
que nous avons à mende
c'est un mélange de styles très réussie
des broderies de fils d'or soir est ici
de pelle robinets en or un luxe très
bling-bling marrakech se mondialise et
tente de coller au goût tape à l'oeil
des nouvelles fortunes mondiales
c'est un goût un peu spécial qui va
sûrement plaire aux indiens au russe
mais pas tellement européen je pense
on verra on verra quand l'hôtel sera
plein si windows phone carole et olav
eux continuent leur visite du palace et
vont de surprise en surprise
qu'est ce que ces projets ces avancées
spectaculaires ça c'est incroyable ce
lustre il est incroyable un lustre de 7
mètres de haut tout en cristal mais le
plus incroyable c'est le plafond qui le
soutient incrusté de plusieurs centaines
de pierres semi-précieuses des broches
multicolores et scintillante comme une
boule à facettes pour milliardaires
et ce plafond un secret un vrai diamant
ils seraient cachés
[Musique]
l'idée folle du maître des lieux le
promoteur marocain jaouad kadiri qui a
soigné le moindre détail pour s'assurer
une clientèle fortunée
il paraît qu'à une histoire à son
diamant on a mis un vrai diamant et la
personne le client qu'il faut y aller
avec une pioche donc à mon avis c'est
vrai beaucoup de clients qui me
regardent sympa et ça peut rapporter
gros
le taz est le dernier né des resort de
marrakech un mélange d'artisanat indien
et marocains placée sous le signe du
luxe et du gigantisme est le nec plus
ultra en la matière se trouve au
deuxième étage comme le découvre carole
et olaf la suite royale de 950 m² pour
seulement deux chambres une suite de
cinéma c'est d'ailleurs ici qui a été
tourné le film sex and the city 2 et
voici le lit dans lequel l'actrice
carrie bradshaw rendu célèbre par son
rôle de journaliste en quête du grand
amour a essuyé ses peines de coeur
durant les trois mois tournage
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour jaouad connue jusqu'à présent pour
sa conception de lieux branchés à
marrakech
cette soirée exceptionnelle destinée à
tester son palace se passe bien mais
c'est demain qu'il s'apprête à jouer une
partie autrement plus difficile
une grande fête avec 300 invités grosses
fortunes jet setteur et people autrement
dit ces futurs clients
[Musique]
8h du matin le tage et ses 200 chambres
deluxe s'éveille au milieu des paliers
mais avant d'accueillir les stars et les
milliardaires
on sache peinture et les artisans
peaufine les finitions en coulisses on
s'agite pour que la fed puisse avoir
lieu dans les meilleures conditions
pas moins de 30 corps de métier et trois
années de travail ont été nécessaires
pour faire sortir de terre le palais
imaginé par chat watts
c'est le principal promoteur mais aussi
le décorateur des lieux et ici il n'a
pas regardé à la dépense
quitte à enduire d'or les corniches des
plafonds jawad 20 mettre plein la vue
combien de kilos d'or entourés peu près
à 20 kg de rap un peu plus il faut
commencer à enlever tous les plastiques
comme ça commence à plat fait tout le
ternaire petites décorations petit coup
de stress
après tant d'années de travail les
invités arrivent dans moins de trois
heures plus de 1500 mètres carré de
plastique qui protège meubles bibelots
et soldes doivent être retirés
un grand nettoyage commence
jusqu'au dernier moment 200 petites
mains vont s'agiter pour que le palais
bride ses mille feux
c'est le plus grand projet jamais
réalisé à marrakech une arrêt mais de
retour et prêt relais pour toutes leur
sont posés en fin de centre et tout est
prêt et tout va aller comme de la magie
c'est ça l'hôtellerie au total le coût
de l'hôtel s'élève à 180 millions
d'euros
un gros risque pour jaouad le promoteur
musique roi
[Musique]
20 heures le palais est enfin prêt et
brille de tous ses feux
les premiers invités arrivent près de
300 personnes le gratin international de
marrakech pour les accueillir
jawad a revêtu sa tenue de maharaja
semblant sa femme priti à ses côtés
c'est la fille d'un grand industriel
indien troisième fortune de son pays et
ça se voit ces boucles d'oreilles en
émeraudes pèse à elle seule près d'un
million d'euros
leur victoire si elle a aidé à financer
une partie de ce chantier pharaonique de
presque 200 millions d'euros
c'est qu'elle aussi mis sur le potentiel
de marrakech ici à marrakech c'est
l'exotisme absolue les gens sont très
gentils il ya une sensualité ambiante
ce serait une aventure fantastique pour
les indiens de venir ici
d'autant que les indiens connaissent
déjà le tage ça pourrait les pousser à
venir et quand ils seront là je suis sûr
qu'ils adorent ont scandé de la bête
en attendant l'arrivée des indiens les
italiens ont pris la pôle position en
l'occurrence eva cavalli et toi comment
vas tu as ma belle ça me fait tellement
plaisir que tous soient là c'est
incroyable c'est la femme de roberto
cavalli pape de la mode italienne
glamour et sexy mais aussi couturiers
préférés de sharon stone
et pour tous les invités qui pénètre
dans l'hôtel c'est la même réaction
d'admiration
je trouve que c'est
le bel endroit de maragha ch
plus bel endroit de marrakech tout à
l'image de jaouen jawad pour son
inauguration mise sur ce qui a fait la
fortune de marrakech les riches les
stars et les amis des stars comme
l'acteur de séries bernard montiel qui
aiment venir ici en compagnie d'isabelle
adjani ou de claudia cardinale
ce soir il retrouve un autre ami orlando
le frère de dalida
bonsoir alors vous trouver l'hôtel
l'automne les majestueux il est énorme
il est grand et c'est un peu la
splendeur à la grandeur du pays
et puis on se plonge dans ses jours dans
sa cellule parce que irrespectueux c'est
combien
mais c'est plus long
quelque chose depuis de doute y voit la
main c'est ça et en les regards se
tournaient la voilà fidèles habitués de
marrakech est la raison oui je suis
passé je pense non pourvu que ça dure
lanton passe pas simplement c'est cette
véritable passion des gens riches et
célèbres pour marrakech qui incite ici
les palaces a poussé comme des
champignons et tous ces hôtels ont le
même objectif attirer chez eux le
maximum de ses clients prestigieux voilà
pourquoi jawad lors à organiser une fête
inoubliable dans l'un des pavillons de
son hôtel un dj mixe pour des danseurs
traditionnels au milieu de gigantesque
plateau de fruits une débauche de luxe
et de moyens qui pourrait bien inquiéter
les autres palaces même si ce patron
d'une célèbre chaîne hôtelière préfère
dire qu'il est venu en curieux plutôt
que pour surveiller son nouveau
concurrent des ravis parce que
attirer encore plus de monde d'aller
chercher les clients encore un peu plus
loin parce que c'est celle en scène dans
très connu dans le marché asiatique et
aujourd'hui on est ravi que les
meilleurs européens et nord-américains
meilleures marques asiatiques également
à marrakech l'homme bref plus on est de
fous plus on rit
à elle seule la ville compte aujourd'hui
plus de pallaske paris mais comment
s'est-elle mise au bling bling et
pourquoi tutelle les riches et célèbres
du monde entier
car pendant longtemps la seule carte
jouée marrakech c'est l exotisme
l'homme qui a fait de cette petite oasis
en plein désert l'un des endroits les
plus prisés de la planète et français et
sont arrivés ce matin à l'aéroport de
marrakech provoque l'effervescence dans
ce jet privé qui vient de se poser voici
pierre bergé mécène dont la fortune est
aujourd'hui estimé à 100 millions
d'euros mais surtout fondateur de la
maison yves saint laurent avec le
célèbre couturier brice jeunes français
de 28 ans a été chargé par la compagnie
de jets de le recevoir en grande pompe
car ici personne n'oublie que la ville
du tout beaucoup comme tout le monde
c'est monsieur père berger quel était le
compagnon de monsieur saint laurent et
c'est un petit peu justement les
précurseurs qui ont lancé la destination
marrakech les années 60
donc voilà quelqu'un de très important
et un amoureux de la ville et qui 5
euros je venais régulièrement on a
acheté une maison plus une autre puce
une autre tue presque 50 ans ça fait
vraiment partie vous en sépare auriez
pendant rien au monde le pays qui
mettrait très très cher je peux bien
et que j'avais fini ma pierre bergé a
carrément droit aux honneurs du pavillon
des chefs d'état s'ils méritent une
telle reconnaissance c'est que
l'incroyable histoire de marrakech avec
les stars se confond avec sa propre
passion avec yves saint laurent dans les
années 60 le couple vient chercher au
maroc a lieu pour abriter son amour
marrakech les fascine c'est une cité
impériale et surtout la vieille ville la
médina recel de ce splendide hôtel
particulier les fameux ryad qui
appartenait au pacha de la cour du roi
par la suite le couple achètera l'un des
plus beaux palais de la ville le jardin
majorelle dans le sillage de berger de
saint laurent ce sont les stars et la
jet set internationale qui se met à
fréquenter marrakech les rolling stones
mireille darc et alain delon auront
aussi leur riad népal et que les
millionnaires sa rage aujourd'hui une
vraie mine d'or qui fait aussi la
fortune des agents immobiliers david est
l'un d'entre eux il y a trois ans il
s'est installé à marrakech pour faire du
business et surfer sur le boom de la
pierre les ryads c'est une bonne partie
de son gagne pain
le monde entier connaît marrakech et le
monde entier connaît la médina
c'est grâce à la médina et aux maisons
anciennes traditionnelles il ya un
attrait aujourd'hui à marrakech et au
maroc donc donc les il ya toute une
catégorie de la clientèle qui qui est
attaché à ces maisons qui sort de
l'aéroport qui arrive en dix minutes à
la médina et qu'ils arrivent de paris de
londres d'un peu partout en europe
et c'est vrai que c'est un lieu mythique
on n'a pas de repères c'est pas des
maisons qu'on a l'habitude de voir en
europe
donc voilà c'est ça un char mais ça a
toujours été
1500 ryad seraient occupés par des
étrangers
parmi ces heureux propriétaires arielle
dombasle et bernard henri lévy mais
aussi des stars de la politique et des
médias comme anne sinclair et dominique
strauss kahn si marrakech fait rêver les
stars du monde entier
elle attire aussi des gens fasciné par
cette aura et par la beauté des riads de
l'année
pour sa retraite pierre psychiatre
parisien réputé rêve de s'offrir l'un de
ses palais il a sept cent mille euros en
poche ce matin david l'emmène visiter un
bien exceptionnel dans le quartier le
plus cher du centre-ville suivre les
vieux rêve un peu plus le temps que j'y
viens la vie de peut-être s'installer
autrement qu'à l'antenne 250 mètres
carrés sur trois niveaux le tout refait
à neuf et avec du coup voilà ce qu'on
peut avoir pour un million d'euros
et à ce prix ce genre de biens s'arrache
alors que ça valait une bouchée de pain
il y a vingt ans je sais que je suis
depuis les prix ont été multipliés par
dix surtout pour ce genre de riad situé
en plein coeur de la médina au premier
étage un salon deux chambres
[Musique]
et surtout une salle de bain très
tendance digne des meilleurs designers
une double douch ancien
les noirs alors ici c'est la pièce phare
du riad enfin salon ouvert
ouvert sur le patio comme la majorité
des ryads avant tout a été rénové à part
les murs porteurs acheter cent cinquante
mille euros il ya dix ans ce palais va
permettre à ses propriétaires de
réaliser un joli coup financier mais le
million d'euros demandés ces trois cent
mille euros de plus que le budget prévu
par pierre le prix de son rêve de star
c'est sûr que c'est pas fait pour faire
une opération immobilière
peut-être y en a qui le font mais pas
moi moi je cherche un endroit à vivre
profitez de l'ambiance l'ambiance de
marrakech il ya beaucoup de gens qui
cherchent à faire des affaires mais ils
veulent quand même salaire correspondait
que ça leur plaise
donc du coup le choix est très limitée
il ya beaucoup de gars qui sont pas de
qualité et les beaux biens se vendent
mais dans un contexte où certains
heureux propriétaires veulent à tout
prix remplir leur tirelire
un petit conseil s'impose aux amoureux
des stars qui ne sont pas milliardaires
gare aux abus donc voilà c'est la petite
façade jaune à marrakech à quartier
permet encore de faire des affaires la
casbah en s'enfonçant dans la médina
c'est le nouvel eldorado sur lequel les
gens riches et célèbres n'ont pas encore
jeté leur dévolu
et le prix au mètre carré sont ressent
750000 euros pour ce riad presque deux
fois plus grand que le précédent
420 m² de plain pied avec un grand patio
arboré
là encore on retrouve les arcades le
chemin avec très bien
ici le riad est vendu meublé mais elle
est à presque brut les décorateurs
branché ne sont pas encore passés par là
ce qui n'est pas pour déplaire à pierre
qui raffole du cachet marocain
il ya un petit côté dans son jus et en
même temps très interprété avec une
tradition avec 6 est plaisant c'est bon
c'est pas du tout le même genre mais
tant qu'à faire d'être à marrakech
c'est comme ça que je vois un peu la vie
à marrakech et voici la propriétaire qui
a flairé la bonne affaire il ya 12 ans à
l'époque ce gigantesque ryad c'est bradé
à 150000 euros aurait toujours évolué
les plafonds en bois de cèdre toujours
ses vastes volumes sur la hauteur
elisabeth en demande aujourd'hui 750
mille euros c'est le ticket d'entrée
minimum pour s'offrir un riad même ici
dans la casbah pour convaincre pierre la
propriétaire va lui faire découvrir le
gros atout de cet endroit
une immense terrasse protégée des
regards où on peut même bronzé dans le
plus simple appareil
mais aussi un endroit idéal pour
agrandir la maison avec une véranda et
tout ça pierre salles inspire maison de
charme est vrai bien sûr en cours soit
que vous ayez eu un coup de coeur
plus de doute cette fois pierre a trouvé
son riad et dans ses prix dans deux mois
il sera un nouveau nabab de la médina
mais aujourd'hui les ryads d'exception
se font rares
il en faudrait plus pour décourager les
amoureux de marrakech alors de nouveaux
quartiers plus branchés se construisent
attirant notamment les stars de la
télévision
et parmi les addicts comme patrick
poivre d'arvor claire chazal ou arthur
certains décident même de s'installer
c'est ce qu'a choisi de faire ce client
qui ne vous sera peut-être pas inconnu
ce matin il vient signer son bail dans
l' agence de david et de son associé
delfina bonjour
l'animateur de télévision et de radio
laurent fontaine partagera désormais son
temps avec femme et enfants entre
marrakech et paris cela fait 25 ans que
laurent fontaine passe ses vacances ici
amoureux de la ville il a décidé de ne
plus jouer les touristes et de louer une
maison je suis maintenant aujourd'hui il
signe son bail
c'est une très bonne destination de
vacances globalement le maroc je pense
que c'est une très bonne installation
pour des gens qui ont envie de couper
que la vie parisienne un peu speed un
peu un peu un peu agaçante un peu
pluvieuse souvent pluvieuses et que
c'est un très bon moyen de se détendre
et de la d'avoir une sorte de résidence
secondaire sympa à j'ai plein d'amis qui
habite marrakech ça c'est sûr plein
d'amis parisiens qui sont installés à
marrakech pour certains qui viennent
régulièrement bien sûr bien sûr c'est
même ce qui fait qu'il ya une vie si
assez particulière parce que marrakech
est une ville extrêmement cosmopolite
c'est peut-être comme la ville la plus
cosmopolite à céline déville avec
barcelone par exemple et que c'est pas
qui bouge où il ya une espèce d'énergie
permanente
donc c'est une ville intéressante procès
à marrakech soit bien sûr riad de luxe
villa contemporaine
mais surtout ce qui a attiré les
milliardaires à marrakech c'est la
surenchère dans le luxe que se sont
livrés les grands palaces avec leurs
piscines leur spa
et leurs services philippe aéroport de
marrakech
nous sommes le week-end de la toussaint
c'est l'ouverture de la saison
chaque année à cette période l'avion en
provenance de paris déverse son flot de
célébrités orlando le frère de dalida
le sulfureux photographe françois-marie
banier
l'actrice et virginie efira et l'acteur
et animateur télé bernard montiel qui
passent ici presque toutes ces vacances
d'hiver et cela pour une raison très
simple
marrakech est très à la mode tout
simplement parce que d'abord il ya un
bel accueil mais ça c'est le maroc en
général c'est un pays très tolérant
c'est un pays où à deux heures d'avion
effectivement il ya le soleil vous savez
ils disent ici dès qu ils vous reçoivent
ils disent bienvenue chez vous et c'est
vrai ils savent recevoir ces constats
que tout le monde vient ici juin l'avion
était plein et puis là actuellement les
hôtels sont pleins aussi quoi et ça y
fait d'être bien accueilli quelques
papiers très bon endroit maintenant
comme à chacun de ses séjours il descend
dans l'un des plus luxueux hôtels en
plein coeur de marrakech est ici pour
l'ami des stars c'est le même service
qu'à monte-carlo
une voiture avec chauffeur évidemment
mais aussi un accueil personnalisé et
chaleureux merci car la propriétaire a
l'habitude de choyer ses clients
célèbres
non
bonjour jeu traditionnel thé à la menthe
ça c'est divin ça y est on est dans le
bain l'a déjà tenait monsieur vous
laurent merci merci beaucoup
tu m'as garder toujours ma jolie maison
chez toi franchement j'ai la chance se
sentir chez lui en vacances c'est pour
cela que bernard choisi de résider ici
c'est grâce à une trentaine de villas
comme celle-ci disséminés dans un parc
de huit hectares que l'hôtel réussi à se
distinguer des autres
un endroit protégé où se réfugient gens
célèbres et fortunés à l'abri des
regards et des paparazzi
il faisait mauvais bien sûr dans un
souci rend évidemment en voiture est pas
question de marcher surtout en vacances
mais c'est gentil oui et les plus
prisées possède jardin et piscine privée
merci un hôtel avec en guise de chambre
de grandes villes à 210 mètres carrés
alors regardez ouais c'est tout à fait
dans le style du pays ni kwg artisanale
magnifiquement décorée avec ses très
belle cheminée
le beau travail aussi sur le plafond
comme ça avec ses lumières et cette
chambre qui est une chambre un peu des
mille et une nuits où je dois avouer que
je réside le plus souvent tout seul
raté pour le scoop pas de scoop pour
nous mais un service vip pour bernard
avec beaucoup d'attention le chef de
l'hôtel s'est souvenu de sa gourmandise
oh ça c'est gentil regarder ce qui me
prépare le chef comme j'ai l'habitude de
venir ici je dors gaza je suis gaga deux
sacres à 4/4 à l' orange avec la fleur
d'oranger il le fait divinement bien
c'est un très bon chef qui est ici tout
ce que jamais là un petit geste
quasiment obligatoire pour fidéliser la
clientèle
et puis le rapidement les dans le détail
aussi quoi je vois les roses
cette villa coûte 1500 euros la nuit et
pour ce prix de milliardaires la piscine
est chauffée
même s'il fait 25 degrés dehors au est
la cumbia est à 29
bien voilà c'est le nec plus ultra sa
propre piscine personnel tout est
ceinturée de verdure et alors ça c'est
exceptionnel quoi parce qu'on est là
chez sois tranquille
c'est formidable c'est ce côté très
privé qui plaît tant aux stars du monde
entier
l'année dernière un célèbre acteur
américain a séjourné quelques jours dans
cette ville a baptisé la favorite est la
propriétaire ne résiste pas à l'envié de
nous faire quelques confidences pour
mettre en avant ses clients célèbres
si je vous dis que leonardo dicaprio et
lula il ne m'en voudra pas un nom voudra
pas du tout voilà et lui en général les
choisit plutôt une villa où il ya deux
appartements de deux chambres
parce que il a peut-être une vie privée
très très intenses avec des demoiselles
qui changent souvent qui se ressemblent
d'ailleurs souvent qu'ils sont toujours
très belle très grande très blonde mais
le grand amour de sa vie c'est tout de
même sa maman et quand ils voyagent
souvent sa maman l'accompagnent en
général ils donnent la plus belle
chambre sa maman et pour les stars qui
viennent en couple il y a même une villa
qui semble recueillir leurs préférences
la ville la berbère est totalement
différente des autres et elle est
surtout dans un matériau qui est de la
terre et elisabeth est intarissable sur
ce nid douillet dites moi il manque pas
un bouquet de fleurs ici
voilà vous pouvez demander à qui est-ce
qui est là d'errani vous lui demandez
qui la porte
récemment marion cotillard et guillaume
canet sont venus y séjourner et les
couples célèbres font la queue pour
profiter de l'intimité que leur garantit
cette vie là au coeur du palace jamal
debbouze est venu au mois de juin donc
il était là avec mélissa autour de la
piscine donc elle a pu se reposer
tranquillement puisque sa petite sa
petite fille n'était pas encore née sa
petite lila nous avons donc eu aussi
sophie marceau et avec christophe avec
elle et c'était très agréable de les
voir dans leur villa et ils se croient
qu'ils ont bien pour bien apprécier
cette vie là les stars attire les stars
en quelques années les gens riches et
célèbres se sont habitués à prendre
leurs quartiers d'hiver à marrakech
aujourd'hui la ville est en train de
devenir aussi légendaire que
saint-tropez et comme là bas on aime s'y
retrouver en bande
on croise plein d'amis partout oui enfin
surtout dans certains endroits quoi mais
c'est très agréable c'est ça qui est
agréable parce que souvent on s'appelle
pas pour se dire
je vais à marrakech c'est ce que tu vas
ce que tu vas pas et c'est toujours un
peu compliqué donc c'est toujours de
belles surprises
quand on croise des amis bonjour c'est
un très grand coiffeur il est également
à saint tropez
elle habitait de coiffer toutes les
stars mais bernard a trouvé une
occupation plus sympathique de se faire
couper les cheveux
il a choisi de s'offrir un bon massage
car ce qui fait le succès de marrakech
ce sont les spas que construisent les
palaces pour garder leur clientèle chic
et celui dont va profiter maintenant
bernard est l'un des plus grands et
luxueux de la ville bien en fait le
phénomène 4 est curieux c'est que les
gens même s'ils quittent paris ils ont
envie de retrouver presque la même chose
ou la qualité de service en tout cas
qu'ils ont à paris ce qui peut paraître
un peu bizarre mais heureusement ici la
porte
en dehors de la qualité il apporte aussi
la différence c'est à dire la tradition
marocaine vrai savoir faire chouchouter
la vma c'est cette véritable tradition
affiche ici des tarif plutôt prohibitif
un massage coûte environ 250 euros il
est vrai que les produits utilisés sont
ceux de l'une des plus grandes marques
de luxe françaises
on ne se refuse rien bernard
alors face à une telle débauche de luxe
comment les autres palaces tire-t-il
leur épingle du jeu et réussi style
aussi à attirer une clientèle haut de
gamme
très loin des villes à un palace a lui
choisi d'offrir aux stars un dépaysement
total
l'impression de vivre comme des pachas
mais version hollywood
voilà pourquoi elle s'est installée en
plein palmeraie à 10 km du centre ville
le couple brad pitt angelina jolie julia
roberts et george clooney ont déjà fait
le déplacement
[Musique]
arrivé tout droit de la grisaille et du
froid parisien
le célèbre designer ora ito 34 ans est
venu s'offrir un week-end dans ce palace
parmi les plus anciens de marrakech mais
qui a su se rendre
indémodable bonjour comment ça va
écouter très bien un peu fatigué par le
voyage mais on va bien se ressourcer là
[Musique]
le directeur en personne vient lui aussi
l'accueillir
c'est alexis 30 ans le fils de la
famille rule qui a créé cet
établissement dans les années 50
ora ito est un inconditionnel de ce bal
à ce qu'ils inspirent pour créer j'ai le
dernier parfum guerlain que j'avais
dessiné sous la coupole d'amour et ça
s'appelait idylle donc c'était
magnifique oued 2 et puis voilà enfin
c'est donc donc grâce à ce lieu
ça m'a permis de faire des très belles
choses parce que c'est important le
l'inspiration le contexte
l'environnement et c'est quelque chose
qui est complètement propice et on se
laisse complètement aller donc pincer
c'est un lieu magique moi dès que j'ai
un petit peu gêné que la page blanche
elle reste blanche je viens ici voilà le
lieu du crime
alors il doit y avoir une espèce
d'énergie en dessous de cette pointe là
je ne sais pas ce qu'il y'a mai mais il
ya un truc en tout cas je me mets là
alors ils ont déjà mes petits crayons
peut s'y connaissent un peu mes
habitudes tout est donc je viens je là
je n'ai pas l'impression de travailler
c'est assurément un des premier lieu à
marrakech qui a qui a initié tous tout
ce live tile on va dire il ya une vraie
âme une histoire et ça l'histoire c'est
ce qui caractérise un lieu
ici les clients célèbres peuvent
s'offrir toutes leurs lubies le palais
les accueille dans des chambres qui
donne tout sur cette piscine monumentale
mais figurez vous que ce que préfère
encore les stars c'est de payer une
fortune pour dormir sous une tente
allez alors tu m'as mis ou cette fois à
la tente à rennes tout seul ça va être
très drôle hein
[Musique]
l'attentât rem au coeur d'un oasis de
verdure mais quand les riches célèbres
se la joue campeurs ils dorment en
réalité sous des maisons de toiles
décoré comme des palais des mille et une
nuits un style bédouins de luxe avec
deux jolis bassin en guise de descente
de lit le matin quand on se réveille
foot c'est une petite piscine piscine
d'amour c'est la première fois que je
que je viens dans les tentes et j'aime
beaucoup parce que c'est encore plus
dépaysant mais on vient encore le
laventure poussé à l'extrême on va dire
mais bon ce sont quand même des tentes
de luxe quand on vous dit on va dormir
dans une tente on s'attend à lavau tente
on va cesser c'est une somme 80 on va
dire l'hôtel est classée parmi les 50
plus beaux du monde et c'est dans cette
même tente qui est descendue l'un des
couples les plus célèbres de la planète
voilà beaucoup plus vidéo couple beckham
david et victoria qui étaient venus qui
avaient réservé cette entente là pendant
pendant dix jours qui viennent ici
personne ne sait qui sont là le savoir
après mais pas pendant la durée leur
séjour ça reste un nombre excessif mais
ce n'est pas seulement pour les coups de
pub que les palace de marrakech
s'arrachent les stars et les people du
monde entier
c'est aussi parce que chacun de leurs
caprices pour apporter très très gros et
une fois encore ce sont les beckham qui
remporte la palme
nous à vider toute la boutique et ils
ont réservé de leur histoire
internationale uniquement pour eux pour
un dîner en amoureux tout le bassin du
restaurant couvert de fleurs dîner en
amoureux des des candélabres et voilà
des lustres rajouter uniquement pour la
soirée qu'on a fait venir de casablanca
pour l'événement car ici presque tout
est possible mais pour garantir ce
dépaysement et ce genre de service
exclusif
les clients ne doivent pas être trop
nombreux l'hôtel compte 45 employés sa
capacité est limitée à 26 clients
à ce compte vous pouvez être bien servis
alain standing qui a un prix 750 euros
la nuit pour 70 de 160 mètres carrés où
ont dormi julia roberts et george
clooney mais aussi un autre couple qui
fascine
angelina jolie et brad pitt
on très gentil très discret ce soir et
c'est ici sont venus sur les enfants à
l'époque je peux pas vous dire combien
il en avait mais c'était déjà une belle
grande famille donc il était venu
vraiment tous les deux pour ce faire
lors du tournage et et se reposer se
reposer trois jours c'était très court
trois jours mais ont apprécié nous ont
laissé un bon souvenir
on a la chance d'avoir vraiment une très
belle chute lente elle vraiment les
habitués qui reviennent voir george
clooney ou la troisième fois c'est c'est
pas mal aux gens des petits des petits
séjours mais très agréable et le palace
continue de mettre les petits plats dans
les grands pour réussir à satisfaire les
envies de ses habitués un avion privé
pour aller déjeuner dans le désert c'est
possible une séance de médecine
esthétique ça aussi c'est jouable à
l'idée venue de cet homme cédric martin
un service très mode
impossible en france hors d'un cabinet
médical ce professionnel de l'esthétique
est un habitué de l'hôtel
seulement il n'est pas en vacances mais
venu pour le compte d'un laboratoire
pharmaceutique dans sa valise que des
produits anti-âge
alors ça c'est pour les rides du front
et nous avons ici des acides
hyaluroniques dernière génération et du
cargo xi méthylcellulose et de
l'hydroxyde apatite pour les injections
des sillons pour repulper les lèvres
pour estomper les rides et adoucir les
lignes du visage une véritable petite
cliniques ambulantes pour ce qu'on
appelle communément une botox partie une
injection collective de ce produit censé
faire rajeunir et dont raffolent les
stars c'est plutôt une réunion un peu
festive pour présenter des gammes de
produits de laboratoire et ses produits
se développeront à la fois au niveau des
spas est à la fois au niveau des des
médecins
médecin ou chirurgien marocain un décor
de rêve un cocktail dînatoire une table
d'injection tout est réuni pour réussir
cette soirée piqûre cet après-midi le
docteur martin attend plus d'une
trentaine de patientes des jeunes femmes
jeunes riches de marrakech à bellevue
comme kenza 26 ans elle aussi séduite
par les nouvelles techniques de
l'esthétique en vogue aux états unis
mais qui serait t'il légal de pratiquer
en france autour d'une piscine
bonjour asseyez vous allongez vous
pouvoir vous ce qui vous intéressait
c'est vrai on peut accentuer au niveau
des pommettes et des sillons
il n'ya pas d'anesthésié ou autre ça
pique un petit peu mais ça fait pas
spécialement mal l'idée pour les
patientes et d'enlever l'aspect clinique
alors je pique ça va ça fait une petite
injection directe pendant près de six
heures le docteur martha va injecter à
la chaîne des membres de la jeunesse
dorée mais aussi des mères de famille
on peut faire des sillons là on va le
faire sans anesthésie avec le dernier
produit dernière génération qui est
instantané d'accord il offre un petit
peu gonflé pendant deux trois jours les
palace de marrakech sont friands de ce
genre de soirée un peu folle qui font le
buzz et leur permettent de se donner une
image branchée à bon compte
pour le médecin c'est une très bonne
affaire si la première injection est
gratuite la suivante est facturé 250
euros et tout le monde veut tenter sa
chance
je veux que mon visage soirs comme ça
parce que j'ai réalisé des séries dc
j'ai un peu les poches ce soir des
anonymes mais régulièrement des
personnalités de la jet set
si marrakech est entré dans le top five
des destinations à la mode c'est grâce à
tous ces palaces et série ya
d'extraordinaire
mais derrière cette façade de luxe et de
réussite vous allez découvrir les
secrets de ceux qui passent leur temps à
satisfaire tous les désirs des riches et
célèbres de la planète
saviez-vous qu'au milieu des souks l'
immense bazar de marrakech se cache le
roi du business de la déco
vous apprendrez aussi que la plupart des
palais des stars et des milliardaires ne
sont meublées ici qu'avec défaut des
copies très esthétique mais beaucoup
moins cher que les originaux l'un des
premiers à avoir eu l'idée de réaliser
des supers copie c'est cet homme antoine
vandoorne arrivée à marrakech en 1998 en
simple touriste aujourd'hui pour ses
richissimes clients ils réalisent du
mobilier et de la décoration de luxe à
des prix défiant toute concurrence comme
ce lustre qui contrairement aux
apparences est tout neuf
6 600 s'inspirer à l'usure houlmann des
années 20 et donc on s'inspirait d'un
lui ce qu'il a fait et ensuite on la
refait nos dimensions on a modifié les
choses bien évidemment salue ce qui
était fabriquée pour un club à
washington
c'est une pièce sur mesure comme ça
c'est fini je pense qu'on sera dans les
25 8 dollar
et si c'est une chose qu'on arrive à
sentir à 7000 $ des objets faits pour
les stars qui rêve de vivre au maroc
comme si elle était chez elle et si cela
coûte trois fois moins cher c'est grâce
à l'absence de charges sociales et aux
salaires particulièrement bas des
artisans locaux
ici un ouvrier gagne au moins de 10
euros par jour jusqu'à moins cher dans
l'offre d'achat animal advienne 3500
euros par mois mais c'est presque bien
pays c'est presque cher par un fort tu
as déjà beaucoup de gens des ateliers
sont plus admis m
gd efficace c'est dans les environs de
marrakech quand wayne fait le plus gros
de son chiffre d'affaires plus
exactement dans la palmeraie plus de dix
mille hectares planté de palmiers c'est
devenu le quartier résidentiel ultra
chic ou le mannequin naomi campbell
notamment fait construire sa maison
depuis deux ans un eldorado pour bien
pis qui peuvent s'offrir un petit
morceau de ce patrimoine mondial classé
par l'unesco
ici pas de maison à moins de 2 millions
d'euros
la dorothée pour absolument qu'on passe
pièce par pièce il faut qu'on regarde
tout tout tout le moindre de pâles
accompagné de dorothée son associé
antoine vient inspecter les finitions de
cette ville à 2 750 mètres carrés
elle appartient à un riche industriel
français qui s'est offert un palais sur
mesure hostile panache et il en prend
possession dans 48 heures c'était ma la
gouvernante qui les reçoit sept chambres
sept salles de bain un salon de 100
mètres carrés
le tout pour 2 millions et demi d'euros
antoine a eu carte blanche pour tout
refaire à neuf les travaux et la
décoration ont coûté à eux seuls un
million et demi d'euros
c'est en fait une maison dans laquelle
on va faire juste du décor et on a fini
par en tours à faire et on a un peut
désosser la maison refaite tous les
salles tout tout tout tout tout là tout
casser les salles de bains savoie
il a entièrement sacrifier la décoration
typiquement marocaine pour recréer une
ambiance années 30 telle que la souhaite
les milliardaires d'aujourd'hui
chaque élément de la décoration est une
copie comme ces chaises recouvertes de
peaux de léopards en fait j'étais là à
la vente saint laurent à l'exposition
l'avant de saint laurent à paris et en
fait on sait ainsi ya deux trois objets
qu'on avait plutôt gras fier qu'on a
fait refaire dont ses petits pouf ainsi
que de la paire de vases et la paire de
colonne maintenant si on met l'original
est certainement plus j'ai dit mais le
fait mais c'est décoratif déjà dit quand
on décore une maison comme celle ci en
france par exemple qu'est ce qu'on fait
on va chez la vache et le designer chez
des gens écrire eu des meubles on achète
on choisit du mobilier et en fait on
achète son mobilier et puis on crée un
décor ici il n'ya pas la personne qui
vend des meubles ou tout du moins y'a
pas de gens qui fassent ce qu'ils vont
de très jolies choses on qu'est-ce qu'on
fait un objet de redessiner les meubles
et des faire fabriquer le parc est super
moi je n'avais pas vu ses prix lavater
faire très très bien si la décoration
était réellement d'époque une telle
maison coûterait plus de 100 fois son
prix
en coulisses et discrètement les
décorateurs comme antoine sont en train
de faire muer marrakech de sa parure
marocaine pour un environnement plus
contemporain et tendance vous avez une
vue on a vu par ici je me lance je vous
montrais c'était avant maintenant vous
avez après bah c'est super c'est parfait
c'est génial tout est parfait antoine
est soulagé les propriétaires vont
entrer dans une maison conforme à leurs
rêves
après leur avoir coûté beaucoup d'argent
elle pourrait bien leur en faire gagner
aujourd'hui les agents immobiliers
l'évaluent à 5 millions d'euros le
double de son prix initial
antoine n'a pas fini de redécorer les
palais de ce qui s'offre une vie de
pacha au maroc
mais pour ceux qui veulent s'amuser à
créer leur décoration eux-mêmes
direction lé célèbre souk de marrakech à
deux pas de la grande place jamâa el fna
en quelques années ce bazar où l'on
trouve de tout à tous les prix est
devenu le passage obligé du gotha
certains de ces artisans fournissent
même des stars et bernard montiel qui on
connaît beaucoup est lui aussi devenu un
client et là je vous amène c'est
peut-être le plus grand antiquaire c'est
lui qui a meublé à l'époque déjà une
trentaine d'années les plus belles
maisons de marrakech
c'est un copain de mireille darc d'alain
delon de tout le monde parce que alain
delon fut quand même des premiers avec
mireille darc a acheté une maison ici
c'est lui qui l'a décoré maintenant il
décore non seulement les plus belles
maisons d'ici les plus beaux ryad les
plus beaux palais de de la palmeraie
mais également il exporte beaucoup
donc c'est une réussite incroyable parce
que du petit qui avait sa petite échoppe
dans le souk de marrakech
il a fait une industrie incroyable et de
bon goût son magasin est l'un des plus
grands de la médina caverne d'ali baba
mille mètres carrés d'objets de
décoration en tout genre grâce à ses
riches clients voici cet antiquaire qui
a fait fortune
mustapha ben lahoucine deux grands
réalisateurs américains viennent même se
fournir est ici
par exemple les scot c'est un ami c'est
on a travaillé beaucoup ensemble de pour
louer des films tout ça à ridley scott
comment tu as fait pour que toutes les
stars viennent chez toi acheter tous les
meubles se meubler avec toi et tout ça
c'est une phase avec les gens donc
[Musique]
son succès il le doit surtout lui aussi
assez magnifique copie de lampes très
coté sur le marché de l'art et dont ses
clients célèbres raffolent ah oui ces
galets mais à vous régaler mustapha
c'est vrai que c'est pas vrai c'est pas
possible ça
gallet un célèbre designer art déco une
pièce authentique comme celle ci
coûterait 5 compte 1000 euros ici vous
payez la copie 2000 euros pas donné pour
une limitation avec le succès des souks
les prix ont explosé et même l'artisanat
marocain coûte cher comme ce lustre qui
a tapé dans l'oeil de bernard
ça vaut combien ça monsieur luminaires
sont tombés raides c'est le fils de
mustapha relais on garde toujours une
prime de garde les mêmes prix depuis
quand depuis hier nos depuis quatre ans
cinq ans parce qu'avant il y avait pas
de client il y avait moins de gens et
cermak et ceci alors c'est pas qu'on
augmente le prix ça il m'a dit mille
huit cents dirhams
ça fait quand même 160 euros ben c'est
trop cher c'est trop cher mon ami c'est
quoi ça c'est quoi
de la peinture celle à tolède oui c'est
joli c'est vrai que ça prend du temps
mais bien sûr tout tout travail mérite
salaire
mais ouais 160 bon mois sans ça va ah
non ça vachement augmenté attends moi ça
fait trente ans que je viens ici
n'étaient pas nés toi bernard n'est pas
une star mais comme elle ils adorent
négocier c'est ce qu'il va faire cette
fois pour un dernier
c'est marc emile c'est ça non ça s'est
passé une référence 150 dirhams donc
mois 50 ça fait combien
moi ça fait moins 10 a fait ça fait pas
beaucoup
225 bon c'est bien tu peux me lamballe
et s'il te plaît plus à ton fils qui
travaille un peu là il fait que rigoler
et sa femme ercis on voit connus ou pas
le marchandage fera toujours partie du
folklore de marrakech
retour dans la ville la privatiser du
palace où est descendu bernard montiel à
marrakech il a ses habitudes très loin
des mondanités ce qu'il adore comme les
stars s'est invité quelques amis chez
lui
ce soir les premiers arrivés adeline
blondieau ex madame hallyday ainsi que
son mari et leur fille âgée de trois
mois
[Musique]
avec le bébé c'est ainsi qu'il a reconnu
à temps si tu dis mais oyonnax les
jolies et je rentre life un peu frais là
le soir entre
atmosphère très décontracté apéritif au
champagne petits fours digne d'un
réveillon de noël
les célébrités en vacances ne se refuse
rien ça c'est du foie gras
et ici elles savent que tout est fait
pour les soutes et même plus besoin
d'aller au restaurant pour se retrouver
entre amis c'est agréable parce que le
resto on a l'habitude de venir dont les
restos de temps c'est un peu pour
changer quoi
là on a un service très particulier
qu'est vraiment le service à la carte
ils sont parfaits et c'est bien comme ça
non c'est très agréable c'est génial
mais voilà je continue à recevoir ici
imaginez un restaurant il ya du bruit et
du monde là au moins on peut se parler
tranquillement on est comme à la maison
en bout dans ce cadre comme ça qui est
exceptionnel on a la chance quand il n'y
a pas non plus besoin de menus pour
commander bernard s'est contenté
d'indiquer les plats qu'ils souhaitaient
partager avec ses convives
c'est au palace de se débrouiller tout
se joue maintenant en coulisses
dans les cuisines c'est le coup de feu
une dizaine de communes chargé de
répondre à toutes les demandes 24 heures
sur 24 c'est ça le service palace à
marrakech
aux commandes le chef sébastien bontour
passer par les grands restaurants
étoilés
c'est lui qui s'occupe du dîner de
bernard donc ce soir vie la sultane
monsieur montiel qui a pris la vie là
comme par habitude
donc il va venir avec adeline avec ça
l'idée donc son petit menu fétiche les
fameuses salade avec les briouates et de
couscous ne pas oublier les pois chiches
l'élan pour aller faire son petit homard
qu'il aime aussi était en cours mais
skient pas ni snacks et avec le petit
même sens et après on lui fera pastilla
alphand d'oranger el-assad orange on
doit être intransigeant sur la qualité
des produits tout là des têtes
ainsi sur la qualité je pense que l'on
est irréprochable
eh ben dis donc on a la chance d'avoir
quand même un terroir très riche au
maroc
donc on a toute la côte avec agadir
essaouira casablanca où tous les jours
en fait on reçoit tout poisson tous les
jours tous frais et donc on est vraiment
privilégié en fait j'essaye de jouer
dans les techniques par rapport à
l'europe donc de garder les bonnes
cuisson sera pas trop cuit de dégraisser
un maximum les bouillons les prix sont
donc d'arriver vraiment avoir un presque
parfait c'est parce que les gens riches
et célèbres fréquentes l'hôtel qu'il a
fallu à tirer un chef français capable
de cuisiner du plat le plus sophistiqué
à la recette la plus simple et surtout
de se souvenir du goût des stars on est
habitué à recevoir les gens importants
et la jet-set
il ne faut pas regarder la dose ses
traits déjeuner donc c'est vrai qu'on
essaie il bel de retenir un maximum
leurs habitudes leur goût particulier
gdc leur faire plaisir à chaque fois
quand ils viennent nous voir
je sais que dicaprio leonard dicaprio
continue alors lui ne manger que des
hamburgers et il restait cinq six jours
où il a montré que des hamburgers
on a eu
catherine deneuve qui adorent nos
salades c'est vrai que marrakech en ce
moment c'est vraiment tendance par 2 par
la jet set qui vient et c'est vrai qu'on
arrive à faire manger des choses
extraordinaires rouge encore de par la
diversité de portes ou les produits
qu'on arrive à trouver dans la ville la
sultane 40 minutes plus tard couscous et
omar arrive comme par enchantement
servi par les majordomes dédié à cette
soirée et puis quand on aime la le feu
de cheminée et quand on aime la
gastronomie marocaine qui est revisité
par sébastien c'est génial moi j'adore
ça et règles de le voir ça me fait
plaisir et en plus il a mis des pois
chiches
comme j'aime voilà bernard et adeline
sont tous les deux à addict de marrakech
pourtant depuis qu'adeline et maman
quelque chose qui sépare super people
pourquoi moi je paie paul tu connais
tous les endroits branchés
ouais c'est vrai oui parce que je sors
pas à paris donc à ça c'est important et
ça c'est important ça ça c'est un truc
hyper important à dire je ne sors pas à
paris ce qui est vrai a dit oui je ne
sors pas paris je saurai si ici ça me
fait plaisir c'est vrai autrement sur
paris proment croyez pas
car pour la plupart des stars ce qu'elle
apprécie à marrakech c'est qu'elles
peuvent sortir comme à ibiza st tropez
miami ou londres
comme dans toutes ces capitale de la
fête les filles sont sexy les dj très
tendance
élégie roboam de champagne nombreux
[Musique]
et dans ces clubs
tout est fait pour que les célébrités
soient choyés s'amuse en toute sécurité
voilà comment bernard montiel s'est
retrouvé à danser à 3 heures du matin
entre deux molosses
c'est très agréable d'un cylindre de
gardes du corps
c'est là en tout cas que les riches et
célèbres terminent leur soirée
l'agrandît bresse de marrakech jusqu'au
bout de la nuit dans la ville de tous
les plaisirs qui ont 20 ans est devenue
l'une des capitales majeur du star
system